extremely lucky to have joyce poole with
us uh joyce is the co-founder and
co-director of elephant voices she is
really the world experts uh
authority on elephants she studied their
social behavior the communication
patterns
of african elephants for over 30 years
and she'll tell us about that
and as far as i think you've dedicated
your life to understanding and
conserving uh
the welfare of african elephants and uh
joyce says um we were lucky enough
actually that jim simons uh introduced
us to joyce
uh and she said that we should talk to
her because i was telling him about the
turmoil project
and i'm so grateful to you that you're
willing to bestow on us your wisdom
and um extremely looking forward to your
to your talk i know you've learned you
have so much to give
you know your studies of ivory poaching
and so many things about african
elephants and i've
read some of your books um i i think
that you had the best
person to open this workshop and please
take the floor and have five more
minutes so we can actually benefit them
i think you need to now share your
screen correct i do
shelfie let me do that first um
uh share and i need to
get this on to places
[Music]
yeah okay so let me start by thanking
you shafi and david and michael and the
simon's institute for
inviting me um i feel so privileged to
be able to
uh speak to you today because although i
know
i feel i know a lot about elephants uh
in some ways i feel um
that i don't know all that much about
communication
you know the topic uh in general
um so i'm i'm joyce poole i'm
actually the scientific director of
elephant voices
and i'm going to try and give you a
window into
the information contained in the
african elephants at least as i
understand it
i began studying oh and i want to just
say
please put on earphones because these um
voices are very low frequency many of
them
and they just don't do very well coming
out of the
um computer speaker uh i began studying
african african elephants in ambassador
national park in 1975
and my early work was focused on
the behavior of males in the sexual and
aggressive state of must
and i documented the postures and and
displays of must males and
including a very low frequency
vocalization that i called a must rumble
and my discovery in 1984
uh together with katie payne that this
and other
uh african elephant rumbles contained
frequencies below the level of human
hearing
led to a long-term study of elephant
communication
during which i have focused not only on
their vocalizations but also
on their other behaviors
during in the early 2000s my husband
peter grandly norwegian
that's why i'm in norway and i formed
elephant voices with the aim
of studying the voices and the behavior
of elephants
as well as acting as a voice for
elephants
and we've worked together on elephant
communication and conservation projects
in ambaseli and masaimara in kenya
and in gorongosa mozambique where this
picture
was taken these projects have allowed us
to observe how elephants with different
histories
and habitats behave during
the last few years we have built and are
currently
populating um an online fully searchable
database that we're calling the elephant
ethogram
a library of african elephant behavior
which we hope to have publicly
available later this year and
uh the ethogram describes 200 and well
over 273
behaviors now and a behavior being a
unique movement or action
and another 85 behavioral constellations
which are a suite of behaviors that
typically occur together
and each of these occur in one or more
contexts so it's as i said it's fully
searchable so
all these uh specific searches you can
take
age uh active body part communication
mode and so on
and here i've selected acoustic vocal
and
so listed below then are all the
behaviors
that are vocalizations that we
have documented that we think we have
some understanding of
as well as the behavioral constellations
in which
vocalizations occur um i'm going to
show you what happens here when you
click on must rumble for example
up comes the must rumble page on which
the must rumble is described
as well as video and eventually photo
and audio
exemplars
so what do we know about african
savannah elephants this is
so brief we know a lot but they have a
complex fission fusion society
uh they're unusually they have an
unusually large social network
relationships radiating out from the
mother offspring bond through
family bond group clan to the entire
population and even beyond to strangers
mothers and daughters remain closely
associated for life
and males leave their families when
they're about
14 years old they're very long-lived
animals um and if left alone by us
human beings they they could live up to
70 years
they're large brained they have good
memories and
they're intelligent they're capable of
empathy social and vocal learning
a behavioral innovation and they're
self-aware
they can make really subtle
discriminations based on
sound on scent and touch
and they have rituals around birth death
greetings and matings etc
so what do we know about african
elephant
acoustic communication well calls
originate in the larynx
and in the trunk laryngo call types
include the very low frequency rumbles
higher frequency calls husky cries
grunts barks and novel or imitated calls
the trump call types are the trumpets
nasal trumpets
snorts as well as novel or imitated
calls
and then there are combination calls
like
combining two types of calls a rumble
roar or a rumble roar rumble
a cry rumble and so on
they may present as isil an isolated
call
a bout of single calls antiphonal
calling overlapping or chorus calling
and 58 of calls are overlapping
so that creates a challenge for analysis
the most common call type is the rumble
and these make up 90 of calls
among free-ranging african savannah
elephants
so work by soltis at all
found that using multi-dimensional
scaling analysis
indicated that there were no
acoustically
distinct rumble subtypes though
he did find quantitative variation
across rumbles
and later work showed that the variation
in rumbles
reflects individual identity
and the voices express both positive and
negative emotions as
measured in amplitude duration variation
in fundamental frequencies
voice roughness first format location
but again did not find evidence of of
subtypes
yet in my own work i found that
specific acoustic patterns of rumbles
as in um the sequence of them
or their what they sound like of rumbles
trumpets and roars can be related to
specific
behavioral contexts and they're
associated with particular
body ear and trunk postures
more recently soltus again now working
in
among free living elephants found that
african elephants have
distinctive referential alarm calls for
humans and also for african honeybees
and this discovery supports the
existence
of rumble subtypes
so before i get into the rumbles i want
to talk about some of these other call
types just to give you an idea of the
variety
so husky cries are produced by newborns
and
infants when they're touched alarmed or
distressed
and mothers and allah mothers respond
immediately
to these calls with comforting and
reassuring
and helping behavior as well as what i
call
coup rumbles so
here's an example of eudora's hours-old
infant calling when it was touched
roughly by a male
very um sound
and infant emmett calling when in
trouble his mother ella
rushes to help
and then there are cries cries are
produced by
infants and calves and these are tonal
calls that are
typically produced as a combination call
as in a cry rumble or a rumble cry
rumble
and they're produced by begging
complaining or protesting
calves and mothers respond respond to
cries by helping the calf
allowing it to suckle or if weaning if
they ignore the calf then the calf will
escalate to roaring
so here's a rumble cry rumble by leia
age one as he's pestered by an older
calf
another cry rumbled by elaine same age
as she's stuck
lying down unable to get up
and then the same individual age four
while begging a rumble cry rumble
while begging for a palm heart from her
mother edwina
who attempts to push her away
roars they're very powerful calls
produced by all age sex classes
and subtypes can be tonal noisy
mixed tonal and noisy or produces
combination calls for example a roar
rumble
or rumble roar rumble
roars express protest hunger pain
um anger or high level social arousal
and those produced in anger protest or
hunger pain
elicit attention or assistance from
other elephants
those produced during intense social
excitement overlap with
chorused rumbles so here is
amy's one-year-old calf roaring when a
lion pounces on her
and the entire family came to her rescue
and ejac aged three roaring as he's
pushed into the swamp
and his mother enid came to rescue him
i hear his infant explorer roar rumbling
in distress and his mother elsbeth ran
to the swamp to help him
from
here is a teenage male roaring when
touched by an adult female
a three-year-old calf is separated from
her mother and gives a rumble
roar rumble we found that separated
calves
often give the this kind of a
combination call
and an adult female gives a pulsated
estus roar as she's chased by males
and these roars are are very
characteristic and they
will um cause more ma attract more males
and then ebony age six contributes a
rumble
roar rumble to a greeting ceremony
[Music]
and then there are trumpets everybody
knows about elephant trumpets
these are produced by all age sex
classes except newborns
so there's several subtypes that i
recognize
protest trumpet alarm trumpet
trumpet blast against predators a trump
pulsated trumpet nasal trumpet and a
sort of
catch-all social trumpets
depending on the on the type trumpets
are used to
intimidate or express alarm surprise
annoyance protests intense level of
social arousal
such as during a bonding ceremony or
during social play
so here's an example of what i call a
protest trumpet
a mother as her infant is pushed by a
young male
and here an alarm trumpet this little
calf age
two ejac is separated um
from his mother and then his mother is
calling to him
a trumpet blast this is uh the famous
ambushed ghidorah when she's charging us
in gorongosa
[Applause]
uh uh trump during social play this was
a young male
challenging us
a pulsated trumpet an adult female
during exuberant play this is typical of
exuberant
play
and also during exuberant play are nasal
trumpets this is a juvenile
and then there's social trumpets um i
call them social trumpets because they
occur during these bonding ceremonies
and
what i'm going to play to you are family
members at an elephant birth
and you'll notice that they're rather
similar to the play trumpets
um really variable
[Music]
and then the novel or calls or and those
acquired through vocal learning um i'm
not sure
if any of you have seen the paper that
we produced in 2005 or we documented
um a if an elephant who was imitating
the sound
of trucks on the mombasa road that were
three kilometers away
so here is one example of this female
and you can see that the the on the
spectrogram
the first one there uh the distant
trucks
[Music]
they make weird all sorts of weird uh
sounds through their trunks
sometimes it seems just for fun here is
a squelch
[Music]
and then the last one is that i have
here is croaking
um this we first heard this by one
female
in one family in ambaselli and soon it
was picked up by another female in the
same family
and now um it has been passed to another
family
it's possible that this is imitation
imitating crickets
uh there's a lot of sound of the
elephant uh feeding on grass
uh during this so you'll have to listen
for the cricket-like sound
[Music]
i want to jump to asian elephants just
for a second
i'm not sure if any of you heard about
this elephant called cosic
at the time that we published the paper
the 2005 paper
uh we were contacted by someone from
everland
zoo in korea uh telling us about this
elephant who imitated
his keeper and was able to say
a number of different words that people
could understand
and angela stoger went over and recorded
and found
he was able to produce nine different
words that were readily
understood by korean speakers and it's
quite phenomenal
we thought it was a hoax at first but he
uses the tip of his trunk
up against the roof of his mouth and
against his tongue
to produce these sounds
so you can see that there's quite a
quite a wide variety of sounds and a
very flexible vocal tract that that uh
elephants have um on offer
now moving to the rumbles which make up
ninety percent of the calls
rumbles are produced by all age sex
classes
all except some produced by young cabs
contain
minimum fundamental frequency below the
level of human hearing
and most contain upper harmonics in the
audible range
duration may be anywhere from less than
a second
to just under 12 seconds
older individuals calls are lower in
frequency
and longer in duration and you can see
here on the the graph
the zero a's are animals less than five
years old
um whereas the the blue triangles the
class
fives are animals over 45. you can see
that there are
some very short rumbles also by that age
group
but that those are these um
the different subtypes that that i i
think
exist uh some calls are very powerful
103 decibels at five meters from the
source
whereas others are barely audible
as i said i think there's distinct
subtypes that can be distinguished by
context
associated behaviors call quality
and measurement and that these
communicate different emotions
needs desires sexual state and other
more specific information
some calls are very distinctive like the
must rumble
while others are more graded and and
more difficult to distinguish
elephants can recognize the voices of
close associates
up to two and a half kilometers away
and they can recognize the voices of at
least
200 other adult elephants that is
the other elephants that would be in
their clan
so recently um angela
and just angela stoger
has come out with a paper describing
oral versus nasal rumbles
so oral rumbles are emitted from the
mouth
as in the mouth is open so they're
open-mouthed
rumbles while nasal rumbles are emitted
from the trunk
and oral rumbles are associated with
higher formats
uh shorter vocal tract and nasal rumbles
with lower
formats and a longer nasal tract
and elephants in are able to adjust the
vocal paths
nasal oral to actively vary
vocal tract length with considerable
variation in
in formats and
as i said oral rumbles are typically
associated with high arousal
and open mouth calling so just to give
you an idea of the difference
the first call is a what i call a
begging rumble
um by ella's one-year-old calf
this is begging to suckle
and here is a beru rumble by
um a complaining rumble by ellsbeth
one-year-old
infant after being pushed away from
another infant by
eudora
you can really hear the complaining tone
in that
peru rumble so these we don't i'm not
going to go into detail here but these
are the
rumbles that i refer to or recognize
um some are nasal rumbles
some are oral rumbles and some like a
contact rumble
falls in both both categories and i'll
come back to that
so i distinguish these by the context
and associated behavior
by sound quality and
um many of them through by measurement
um so there are different patterns of
calling there's a single
uh single isolated call and a must
rumble is a good
example of that but there are also what
i call a v8 rumble
grumble rumble comment rumble um
and and others but just i want to show
you
some of the associated associated
behavior
um of these particular some particular
calls
um in in different uh calling patterns
so this particular call is is a
is a very distinctive pulsated rumble
that's given by males in the heightened
sexual and aggressive state of must
and each male has a very different call
sounding call it's associated with
particular behaviors
uh ear waving trunk dragging
urine dribbling foot scuffing and if
there are females nearby
it will be answered by a female chorus
so these calls are given as a threat in
this case
to me during escalated contests
um in response to other low frequency
sounds including
approaching airplanes and cars
when drinking mud splashing or marking
when approaching a group of females
and immediately prior to mating
so watch for his trunk dragging and his
ears
my
um and then there are bouts of single
calls
um and i'm gonna show a little video
of a grumble rumble see a bunch of
grumble rumbles
um and and these are undulating
rumbles of medium duration with an
audibly detectable
complaining or whining tone and they're
typically heard when the calling
elephant has been thwarted in some way
or uh mistreated um
and it may escalate to a baroo rumble a
louder
more open-mouthed call it's not
associated with any kind of ear flapping
in this video nalakiti who's the
tuskless female there
has her six-year six and ten-year-old
sons
begging for food from her and she's
getting
gets a bit fed up and she gives a
grumble rumble
and she shares two twigs with them but
the younger one
can't reach them and he grumble rumbles
and then he touches her he's very
naughty
she redirects aggression toward her
older son who grumble rumbles
and meanwhile the younger son goes
around behind her
and she kicks back at him she's really
getting fed up and he grumble rumbles
and then he comes around the other side
and begs and she head swipes at him
and he grumble rumbles so you can hear
from different age animals
how this call sounds similar from one to
the next
that's the mother she drops a twig
now they're really rather a lot like um
like our families
um and then there's antiphonal calling
by two or more
individuals and i'm going to show you um
i give an example of a contact rumbles
between uh eudora and arduino and some
distant elephants and you can see
on this the distant the the on the
spectrogram you can see the distant
elephants
but you can't really hear them as only
the
the very low frequencies persist
so here we go
you don't hear the distance
the two elephants talking on top of one
another
a distant answer again and then the two
calling again
and another distant call so
the contact rumble is is really
distinctive
um has a very distinctive uh pattern of
antiphonal calling between
closely bonded individuals who are
separated
um but yet even though i call it a
contact
rumble or contact calling the calls can
be quite
different one from the next so there's a
an initial call
it tends to be an oral rumble and the
answer
an oral rumble and then there's a
confirmation what i think of as a
confirmation call
which is a nasal rumble and these all of
these have
slightly different uh forms or tones and
format modulation for instance
the the answer is a very sudden abrupt
call whereas the the call going out
has almost a sort of a more question
mark sound to it
and these are associated with head
raising when the
when the elephant suddenly hears a sound
with the ears stiff um and listening
behavior that involves
uh the head swinging back and forth to
try and localize the sound
and then ear flapping when the elephant
is calling
and these calls appear to be directed
towards specific individuals based on
behavior
but we don't know that for sure so here
is a young
young female with a newborn she's alone
she's resting and she suddenly lifts her
head her ears are stiff
so she's heard a call and answers now we
hear distant callers
she listens ear spreading and head
swinging
she pauses again still listening
and then gives what i call a
confirmation
the problem is these calls all look
different
so um then there are most anti-funnel
calling
involves overlapping calls so here's an
example
of a little greeting rumble first
first aaron and then enid so it's
typically
a nasal rumble as an animal is
approaching
and an oral rumble by the animal who is
approached
it sounds like this
uh and what i call an as touched rumble
uh
calves when they're touched by older
members of their family
will will give this rumble and you can
see at the beginning there are calls by
mother and sister and also afterwards
and then he gives the
louder call
i believe that this call develops into a
little greeting rumble
and then cadence rumbles these to me are
the most fascinating calls
um because they have a cadence like a
conversation
um and these these ones are between enid
and eleanor
which was part of an hour-long vocal
exchange
through which they work together to turn
their family around and go in a
different direction
so it sounds like this
so so even in this exchange the calls by
the same individual those louder ones
look different and yet they're part of
this long
whatever they're discussing the median
number of overlapping calls in about is
two
uh interquartile range two to four
but we have had as many as 64
uninterrupted calls
overlapping calls so i want to show you
what a little greeting
rumble looks like it's very distinctive
and the behavior is is also distinctive
it's associated with one uh one elephant
approaching the next
head raising ear lifting rapid ear
flapping and sometimes temporal gland
secretion
and other breeding behaviors such as
trunk to mouth
and trunk to genitals so here this young
female approaches another young female
with a calf she calls
touches the baby
notice the head raising and the lifted
ears
so this is a kind of classic little
greeting rumble
so they they'll be they'll have been in
the same group they haven't been far
apart but it's
just sort of like hello it's nice to be
near you again
so um unfortunately i don't have
audio for this but i want to show it to
you because it's a sort of a classic
example
of the use of let's go rumbling and and
cadence rumbling that are often
used together the let's go call is a
is a very long uh unm unmodulated nasal
rumble
um and it's typically given by one or
multiple callers uh working together
to get to to to get elephants the other
members of the family to go in a
particular
direction and it's associated with
particular behaviors
such as waiting walk waiting
body access pointing ear flapping
looking back and in tension movements
sorry i meant to say that's an example
of a let's go rumble
but here's the behavior so here's a
group of elephants
in the heat of the day the matriarch is
marked with an m
big mama and a group of this family want
to head
south and they start to walk
walk wait take a few steps and stop
and point in the direction they want to
go meanwhile
the matriarch is pointing in the
opposite direction this
this was a very long sequence i
shortened it
um again walking and waiting and
when you see the ears flapping um
quite rhythmically then that's calling
like there that would be
a call so these guys are calling and
pointing
south and the matriarch pointing north
now
now they start probably getting into
cadence rumbles i can't be sure
but the ones facing south
then are persuaded to turn around
the direction the matriarch wants to go
that is
not always the matrix doesn't always win
very often a young
member of the family can persuade um
the elephants to go in another direction
or they may split
and sometimes the discussions that go
around
in um deciding this watch the matriarch
now she's going to give a a hard ear
slap
which is okay now i'm moving and she
gives another let's go
and takes off and everyone follows but
as i said sometimes
they will agree to disagree and go their
separate ways
sometimes they appear to agree on
some sort of a compromise
um and then there's chorus calling by
numerous
individuals um here i've just
i kind of have these it lump them
together as
uh bonding ceremonies but we we do
um uh describe mating pandemonium
female chorus greeting ceremonies and
then there are others like
coalition rumbles um
so i'm not going to play these these are
far too long but i'll play a little
snippet just so that you can
uh get an idea of what they sound like
um
i'll play this from the mating
pandemonium
and you'll notice these powerful oral
rumbles are overlaid with trumpets
and roars so this includes the esther's
female who's just
mated as well as members of her family
wow
[Music]
and and then i'll play these
what i call coalition rumbles this is
when the
the lion pounced on on amy's infant
and uh she called uh faced the lion
and her calling was immediately
responded to
by more distant members of the family
who then came
and helped uh them face off this lion
so i i always refer to elephants as
drama queens and it's particularly
because of these bonding ceremonies you
know
any little thing can happen in the
family that
really will set them off um and so i i
do use this kind of catch-all
term for these powerful throaty oral
rumbles that are given in chorus
when something happens in the family
that deserves celebration like a
greeting a birth a rival of a must mail
a mating
or requires females to work together
like
to assist or show sympathy for a family
member
form a coalition take diff collected
defensive and offensive action something
that we saw
repeatedly in gorongosa um
yeah pretty scary and
these high-intensity bonding ceremonies
are accentuated by social trumpets
snorts
roaring or combination calls like snort
rumble
rumble roar rumble and they're also
associated with head raising
ear lifting rapid ear flapping temporal
gland secretion
urination defecation tusk clanking
open mouth to open mouth trunk twining
and so on um in this
in this video um the matriarch has a
newborn it's
perhaps a day old and there's a little
aloe mother an
adolescent female trying to take care of
the newborn
and the matriarch is not too happy with
her
uh yeah her her involvement
um and so in this video the matriarch
pushes the adolescent uh aloe mother
away
and she the allen mother inadvertently
knocks over the matriarch newborn
and so everyone goes crazy uh the infant
roars and family members
uh touch him and rumble and snort and
trumpet
and so i just decided to have a little
fun with this
because um it's it's just cacophony of
of sound uh but but i decided
i would like to put what i think the
elephants are saying it's a little
gimmicky but you know what the elephants
are saying to one another
and um and in doing so i realized that
i actually recognized some of the the
calls whereas before
it was just a you know a mess of
of sound so what i've done here is
put the the individual elephants are
named and the calling elephant the
writing appears over the calling
elephant and you can
you couldn't just enjoy yeah
so in summary we know that individual
identity
arouser level or emotional state is
encoded in
elephant rumbles but can these be
detected across
other call types can format variability
within
rubble subtypes or context types offer
more detail
about what elephants are expressing to
one another
we know that elephants use vocal
referential signals
and we observe elephants to coordinate
movement and actions
apparently discuss with one another
negotiate
make plans reconcile conflicts
sympathize with one another and so while
rumble context types are highly variable
in some cases and may in some cases only
be subtly different
the elephants themselves show by their
consistent behavior
that they're able to discriminate
emotion and meaning
in these graded calls so can machine
learning help us to decipher
what specifically they're able to say to
one another
and i've defined a large number of of
call subtypes
based on sound quality behavioral
context and
measurements but can machine learning
confirm these subtypes for instance
is a greeting rumble different from a
rumble given
in a different sort of bonding ceremony
can a
begging rumble be consistently discerned
from a separated rumble
or a let's go rumble from a cadenced
rumble
we think that elephants are able to
direct their calling
to particular individuals can machine
learning help us
to determine whether elephants are using
signature rumbles
and finally wind noise and overlapping
calls
pose particular challenges to the
automated analyses
of elephant calls so can computer
technology
isolate individual calls within these
complex
choruses or those contaminated with wind
or other frequency
other frequency low frequencies noise
and thank you so much to many many
people
thank you
i guess i need to stop the
stop the share
thank you so much joyce fantastic
um i think we have maybe a couple
minutes for if somebody wants to unmute
themselves ask the question
uh i have a question go for it bernard
uh yeah this is a fantastic talk i have
a question about the
sort of universality of this sort of
language like if you
if you took elephants from a different
breed maybe elephants in asia or
something would you recognize the same
patterns of communication or do you
think
yeah well i i did um we did have a short
project in sri lanka
and although the calls are quite
different
i remember thinking well at least i
understood the elephants better than i
that i understood the sri lankans
speaking their language no but um
there are some similarities but there
are also also differences
um
looking at whether there might be
dialects in in different
um different populations for instance
we have we that the calls sound pretty
similar for instance from
from amboseli to down to mozambique
um and we have done some playbacks of of
calls
uh in botswana the elephants there
recognized them
as seemed to recognize them as different
they were they responded differently to
those calls so
but but we don't have answers really to
your question
thank you
anybody else uh we have in the q a
uh joyce can you see that there are a
couple of questions i think there are
questions
um i can see something but it says
yes i can read it to you it says joyce i
enjoyed your talk humans are vocal
learners too
some of the calls could be made by us do
the elephants understand if you try to
call them
in their own language oh
that's such a great uh question um
i have to admit it's a bit naughty but
um
i have i can make play trumpets
i'm not so good anymore but i i did one
day make a
play trumpets to this elephant this
juvenile who was going berserk around
the car
and those play trumpets got her so riled
up
and the other youngsters so riled up
that
one of them came and sat down on the
bonnet of my car
another one stuck its tusks in
up onto the roof above my head literally
and i just
had to like i mean these are wild
elephants
another one came running at the car she
managed to find a tin
can out in the park i don't know how but
had that stuck on the
tip of her trunk so i can certainly
make play trumpets and get them playing
if it's the right time of the day and if
they're in the right mood
what's it i guess i have a question
what's the value of the data that you
have
how much data oh um
well it's it's yeah i think we we talked
about that before
i'm not sure i have it at the top of my
head um
not not not enormous uh
volumes like the elephant listening
project has
just got recorders out in the forest
recording you know
24 hours a day kind of thing so ours is
all sitting with the elephants
and recording behavior at the same time
but we do have you know we have hundreds
of hours
okay if there's no one else with
questions i think we'll move on to
lilac okay i think i think there are
several questions in the chat
so martha minow is asking uh a few
questions